Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier and welcome to Depth.
Now this game came out a while ago and I, uh, never played it because I find it fucking TERRIFYING!
Legitimately it's a game where you play as a diver down deep in the ocean,
And apparently other players can be the sharks and all the things go BAD and then you DIE...
and it's just something that, uh, I don't know, I've never really been too much into
But I'm just gunna, I'm gunna play cause I, oh fuck you man, oh God
See Subnautica I've gotten used to because there aren't SHARKS in Subnautica
There's shark-like creatures, but there's not SHARKS in Subnautica
But in this game, it's literally sharks, and I fucking HATE sharks
I fucking hate sharks among many things that are in the ocean, but sharks are fucking bullshit so
I'm just in a random, multiplayer game because I feel like if I was actually playing with my friends
it wouldn't be nearly as scary. What friends are that you ask? I have no idea
Anyway, so, I'm gunna be, I'm gunna be Finn. I dunno maybe. Oh god, I have no idea how to play
I'm already sorry all my fellow teammates, I'm not gunna do well.
I'll get the spear gun, I, I guess... I don't know. I got no cash. I gotta knife..?
A knife or a, a chivalry knife. Ahh, either way this isn't gunna be good
GOOD LUCK TO ME I GUESS!! Ahhhh this is gunna be goood.
(Mark Reading Someones Comment) "Sharks don't have butt, BumBums are like butts, right?"
(Mark Replying ) "Ah, Indeed. Indeed, a nice, supple buttocks"
I mean, Sharks don't have buttholes yet, but I'm about to insert a butthole
OHHH *gasp* I hate it already ohhh I hate it already
Oh no, hi S.T.E.V.E, ok I guess. Bye S.T.E.V.E! Ok I guess. Ohh no
Ohhhhh no! My fellow crew mates are already going insane...
I don't even know what I'm supposed to do, I don't oh fuck no, oh no
Oh no, oh they're dead! Why are they dead?
Can anybody talk to me? I don't know how to voice communicate.
But I imagine it's probably bad. OH AHH GOD! OH FUCKING FU-FUCKING FUCK! WHAT THE FUCK?!
What the fucking FUCK?!
OK I'll respawn by S.T.E.V.E! OhhaaHHHH! Holy fucking shit I, ahh, fuck is he in here with me?
I saw something, OHH MY GOD! OK, I'm-a-nu help, I think?
Oh god OH GOD OH GOD! Fucking god! Ohhh fuck... I killed a shark? HOW?
I didn't know I killed a shark! Yay! I did something, Oh good ohgoodohgoodohgood
I love being here, oh I love being here, oh I love being here AHH
Fucking where AHH FUCKING WHAT? Ohfuckohfuckohfuckohfuck I'm gunna get ya, I'm gunna get ya
I'm gunna get ya, oh where you going? Where you going buddy? huh?
Go, ohh shit
That don't look good
AAH! FUCKING WHAT?
AAH FUCKING WHAT?
Oh, fuck, oh God, ohGodohGod...okay
Oh fuck, man that's so fucking ter-uh-ho my God
Why is that so fucking terrifying?
[heartbeat noise from game]
That is soo terrifying.
Hooly fuck.
'Cause you have no idea where the fuck they are!
Oh my God! ohmyGodohmyGodohmyGodohmyGodohmyGodohmyGodohmyGodohmyGod (x9)
I hate this, I hate this!
Oh my God, I hate this!
Oh, God, where are they?! UuUuUUuh! I'm out in the open.
That's not good. Oh, God, they're in there. Oh, I gotta find them
Gotta kill a shark! I killed one shark, I'll kill anooootheeerrr!
...Oh he's dead. Okay.
Hah! Cap'n Stubbs: "That's it! A good haul in tha--" AAAAAAAAAHHHHHHFUCK!
*sighs* Fuck.
Just tryna read what Captain Stubbs was talkin' to me about.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, fuck, dude.
Where are they?
Oh, shit. Shit-fuck-okay.
Where is it?
Oh, fuck.
Ho-fu-hey! Fuck.
S.T.E.V.E. Alright, Steve? Okay, S.T.E.V.E.
Oh, fuck. AAIH-FUCK! Y'MISSED ME, BITCH!
FUCKIN--! Oh, fuck, he's dead, okay.
S.T.E.V.E. is opening that!
Oooh, fUCK you!
Goin' to S.T.E.V.E.!
Sharks don't have buttholes but they soon wiiill!
I should get in there; that's probably important.
Ooh, God. Oh, God, ohGod, S.T.E.V.E., don't kill--Don't kill me. AAIH, fuck.
AAAH, AH FUCKIN' NOoO. Shit you don't.
I damaged you. I damaged you! I KILLED yoOOoou!
HEY! YES! My guy is fuckin' not doin' well, but...
My boy, mah boy.
Oh mah boy. Where'd ya go, mah boy?
Oh mah boy. Where'd you go? Where'd y'go, boy?
That's not reassuring.
Ooh I hate this!
God, this is so stressful!
This is why I didn't fucking play this game, 'cuz it's fucking terrifying!
I hope everybody can hear me right now.
Oh my GOD! Oh my God, ohmyGodohmyGodohmyGod.
Oh my God. I-did I do that? I think I did that.
OhmyGod, ohmyGodohmyGodohmyGod. Five--I don't know what five means.
The fuck does that mean?
I'm repairing S.T.E.V.E.
I guess that's goOOd?
S.T.E.V.E. is--hEey, fuck.
AAH! FUCK! Good God!
It's so sudden!
Is that my butthole?
Gotta stay mobile, is the thing.
That--That guy was still breathing a bit. Or maybe that was his last breath.
I don't know.
Oh boy.
Woah! Oh boy. Good, good, good, good on you! Good on you.
AAAAAAAAAH
FUUCK
Man, barf is tearing me apart, maan!
It's a good thing we can respawn.
Maybe I should buy more guh-ayy--fuck.
*sighs*
AAAH--FUCKING--GOD DAMMIT
Fucking hell; Jesus Christ.
Okay, S.T.E.V.E. is on the way.
Good job, S.T.E.V.E.
Doin' us all proud, S.T.E.V.E.
Doin' us proud S--AAH, FUUCK!
Fuck. God, it gets me every fucking time.
And it's like the girliest scream, I'm sorry.
Oh, fuck. I don't--AAH! Gotcha! I think.Oh, boy.
Oh, I see ya over there.
Why is--Why is he jingle-bellin'?
Why is he jingle-bellin'?
I don't know why he's jingle-bellin'.
Okay, I repair him, I think.
[heartbeat sound from game]
Oh, God, that sounds bad--AAH!
Fucking I th-I th-AAH!
I showed it. Oh, he's dead. Okay, thank you for the assist!
I think I'm bleeding profusely--- Nailed ya!
Oh fuck, I missed. Nailed ya! Nope, missed again. Nailed ya? Gotcha!
HAHAHAHAHEHEHEHOHO
Man, this is actually pretty difficult for the sharks, I imagine. What is that?
Some sort of... Beacon- Oh shit- Oh THAT'S A FUCKING- I walked right into that!
Whoaa. Somehow alive.
What's that? What is that?
I don't know what that was- Did that help mee?
AHHH!
Fuck. Where??
AH! Fuckinnn' NOOOO!
Whoa- Got 'Chu, Barf! Or- We got you. As a team. Togther, like friends do.
*Singing* Preparing S.T.E.V.E, Preparing S.T.E.V.E. *Normal* Yeah, I'm almost dead.
HEY! F- I'm dead. Okay, I'm dead. Hoh, ah fuck.
I have no idea if I'm doing well or merely mediocre, or poorly.
All I know, is that I don't wanna die!
Oh, there's a shark nearby, isn't there? That means there's a shark nearby..
*Scared Mark Noise*
Okay.. OH, that's handy, the sea mine- AHHH! FFFF- I BLEW UP!
I BLEW UP!
I BLEW UP, I BLEW UP I BLEW UP!
Fuck man. *Heavy Breathing*
Ah!
Whoaa.
I thought I gotta-
WHY? No you don't-
Oh God, he's still alive. He's doing everybody! He's doing- AAAAAH! FUCK!
He's DOING- He did everybody! He killed- How did he kill everybody!?
Because I sucked ass, and didn't shoot 'em. That's what happened.
That's how that works- Noooo- Reparing S.T.E.V.E, reparing S.T.E.V.E.
I dunno if this is the thing I'm supposed to be doing, BUT I'M REPAIRING S.T.E.V.E!
*Dramatic Inhale* I CARE ABOUT S.T.E.V.E!
*nervous Noise*
Whoa fuck.
Oh- I can- I can- I can- Dodgee!
Have I've been doin' that?
I can dodge- AH, FUCK!
I gotta get with my team. That's what the hint says! I gotta be with my team!
Oh- I see you there. Whoa- He's got somebody!
Ohhh that's not good..
Okay..
Whoa- Fucking, NOOO!
Come at me! Bitch, come at me!
Oh- AH! Fuck..
WHAT! GOD DAMN IT! Behind me? Son of an ass...
Whaaat? Oh noo!
I did bad...
But I didn't do as bad as 'Sharks Don't Have Buttholes'! Oh fuck.
Okay, weell, that was a thing! Ohh boy.
*Ehh Noise* I dunno how that went. I dunno what happened.
I unlocked the twin pistols.
*Reading* "Carrying two of these is a smart choice for bringing more fire power into the fight."
Maybe the spear gun was like a bad choice. I have no idea.
*Sigh* Okay..
Oh, there's a lot of maps here. I'm not okay. I'm not okay.
My heart is going a million miles an hour.
I feel like I have to do that again to just to... Show it up.
But this time imma go for a Megalodon hunt.
I don't thinks it's gonna go WELL, but-
It can't get any worse then it just did!
Ooh fuck.
At least everyone seemed to be nice. Except for the murder that was happening.
You know what- Okay, I'm just gonna- Imma find another match.
I-if I find another match, I'm gonna try not to... Uh...
To scream like a little girl so much, because that seems to be a problem of mine.
Every single time a shark got me, I think, a shark screamed.
..And that's embarrassing, so...
Let's try to sack up a little bit, because this is not going... Too well for me.
Ooh boy. Money, money, money, I don't have any money.
I've got seven.. I've got eight hundred bucks. That's all I got.
Welp, spear pistol, I did that, so let me try the um..
*Super High Pitched* Lets try the affordable choice, 'cause that's what I want when my life is on the line
something affordable.
Yeeep. Pretty much, I'm ready. Okay-
Alright.
I guess..
Not really much else I can do besides scream like a little baby. Oh boy..
God, I really hope no one can hear me.
Oh, hey guys.
Hey, how's it going? Get ready to die a whole bunch, huh?
Like a lot. Hm. Yeahh, that's probably true.
Okay.. Just gotta kill me some sharks.
Just gotta kill me some sharks, get in there quick and kill me some sharks.
*Reading* "Good luck, have fin." This guy's a funny guy.
This guy's a funny one.
Oh- aie aie..
Oh god.
Oh god. Okay, alright.
Okay.
Oh boy- That's not a good place to be.
Where's the shark-os?
Where's- Ohhh fuck.
W-AAH! F- It's right there! Fucking- *sigh*
Of course I'm the first guy dead! Of course! Of course I'm the first guy dead!
Okay, okay, okay. Get back in there.
Let's get Steve. Oh boy- A shark is nearby, huh?
Whoa God.
Was that a shark? Wait- Did a shark..? Ohh. Oh fuck.
*Gun Shot Noises*
Oh God.
Whoa- Ok. Kill the shark! AHHH!
Fucking- Ugh.
Whoa- Wow, I'm still alive I can't believe that.
Oh wow.
Well that's not good- I'm bleeding, soo..
They probably know exactly where I am.
I'm bleeding profusely. I'm literally covered in blood.
Well that's not good. That's- That's probably not good.
Ahh, the finest riches in Davy Jones' locker.
Let's go find some more booty, shall we?
Yeah, let's doo that.
Oh,  that- AH!
Welp, that was...Quick.
So, apparently, like, we can go get some stuff.
What is that?
E? Okay, picked up treasure!
Oh I get it.
Man, these sharks are a lot less- Whoa- Oh fuck- Only four bullets, I should be careful about me shooting this!
Man, the last sharks we played against we aggressive as fuck-
Whoa!
Man- Ah fuck, they got me.
Oh, but you're dead now!
Who, I'm blewed I'm blewety. I'm very blewety.
So the point is to always stay mobile while also not jumping immediately into their jaws.
Their gaping maws.
Man, I wish I had more shots than four. Four seems like a- Like very few
shots to bring down into the depths. Ya' know.
Seems like a little- A little lack-luster.
Whoa, I saw that!
Whoa God.
Whoa- God! Oh God!
Whoa- He got 'em. Oh my God he got 'em. OK I am in the wrong spot.
Aie aie aie--
Gotta get this- Getting this.
Whoa boy- Can't move. I am very slow right now.
Oh I'm a sitting duc-o-k.
I'm a sitting dick! Ah, fuck, I hate it, I hate it, I hate it. Oo fuck.
Ah! Fuck. What? Who? Where? And why?
Whoa- Whoa-
Hooly shit.
Holy shit.
Oh no, that's not good.
Ohp- Well that probably is painful.
Uh-oh.
Miss me, I think?
Okay- Alright, cashed in treasure.
I think this is going surprisingly well. All things considered.
Wow, okay.
Alright then.
Uh-oh.
Whoa- My God.
Is that behind me?
Oh shit it was.
Holy shit.
How did that not get me?
How'd they not get me?
Oh boy.
Oh boy, oh boy, oh boy.
OH boy-o.
Oh boy-o, Where, where?? Oh fucking boy-o..
GOTCHA! SAVED YA! SAVED YOUR LIFE!
Did that. I did that! That was me, that was me that was me! I did all that.
What? Oh, one of the sharks just disconnected.
Ohh. Apparently we're winning!
Very much so that people is rage quitting.
Okay, alright- Uh starting to get dark.
Woo- Fuckin'-
Boy-o? Boy-o?
Ohhh, they got a bot now. Oh okay.
Alright then.
Waph! Sorry?
Oh God.
Oh fuck.
Okay...
These guys are much better than I am.
I'm just lucky that I'm along for the riide.
THANK YOU ALL FOR ACCOMIDIATING MY LEVELS OF SUCK! Because they are excessive and extreme!
Oh god- OH GOD OH GOD!
What the fuck- Something blasted that out..
Oh my God, Oh my God oh My God oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god.
AH!
FUCK!
Oh fucking fuck. Oh fucking boy-o I got that one.
Oh boy-o.
Okay, we're almost done I think.
Steve's just bursting with loot!
Yees, time to take this haul back to the boat!
Protect Steve with yer' lives!
Okay, thanks Captain Stubbs. I dunno why we have to.
But OK.
Fuck.
Sorry, Steve.
Oh boy.
This is bad. This is bad-sounding. This is bad.
Ohhh
He's jingling with all the loot inside of him!
Oh he's just jingling with potential! For loot!
Oh boy.
They're floating around here somewhere. I dunno where.
Whoa fuck- I heard that!
Whoa fuck.
Oh boy.
Okay- W-AHHH- FUCKIN' WHYY? FUCKING WHAT THE FUCK?
DID I DODGE THAT??
I FEEL LIKE I DODGED THAT!
Oh boy.
'Cause I- FUCKING Whereee??
I don't see anything..
Fuck, I saw nothing.
I SEE NOTHING!
I-I DAMAGED YOU!
THAT'S WHAT MATTERS! I DABLEDGED!
Oh fuck.
Save Steve.
Save Steve! I do.
I better get a lot of money out of this.
Oh fuck, Whoa fuck.
Am I the only one around Steve?
I'm the only one around Steve.
Why am I the only one around Steve!?
Oh God, thank you.
I'm not the only one around Steve.
Dodge?
WH-WHOA DAB YA! FUCK!
Owwwww-eeeee
Ah fuck, I got fucked.
Re-repairing-Ah- Oh. My God.
Stop it!
Hooly shit.
Got that one, apparently.
I did that, that was good.
Okay! Good!
Shit-fuck.
Well, Yay! I-I-I think we did it!
Holy shit, I think we did it!
Oh my this- Oh fuck.
Oh boy, oh boy, OH Boy-o!
Oh, not over yet.
Oh boy, That's not good.
That's not good.
Okay. We're-
Steve's up there.
Alright- WHOOOAAAAHAAAYYYE!
YEAHH!
I  SIX KILLS WITHOUT DYING!? Oh- Kill assist.
Well, Lane and Pown Beard seem to do a lot better than I did
but I'm still better than Adam Bomb!
By only a little bit...
By small metrics..
It's too bad the other guy disconnected, but-
He was the better one after-all.
I dunno why he disconnected.
Oph- Sixteen kills as diver. IS that good? I have no idea.
Yeah, when you win, brag about it.
That will make a good player, I guess.
Okay, so anyway-
That is Depth.
*Inhale*
*Exhale*  Fuck.
Ah man, that game's so scary.
I've never played that game before in my life. But,
I can see the appeal.
I-it's frickn' horrifying.
In every way.
But, you know, it's okay
Maybe I should've take the tutorial!
Maybe that would've been a good idea!
I just like diving in there, you know what I mean?
A little pun action over there..
But either way,
Thank you everybody so much for watching, let me know what you thought in the comments below
AUH
If you want to see more of this, maybe with our.. Friends.. Let us know as well.
That was fucking terrifying.
So anyway, Thank you everybody so much for watching,
And as always, I will see you in the next video. BUH-BYE!
* Music*